raciale donald trump avait programmé ce
même jour à tulsa dans l'oklahoma un
grand meeting de campagne pour sa
réélection en novembre une ville marquée
par le massacre de 300 afro américains
en 1921 le chef de la maison blanche a
dû reporter son grand rendez-vous à
demain
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi les
dirigeants des pays européens réunis
aujourd'hui virtuellement pour débattre
du plan proposé par la commission
il prévoit un projet plus fédérale qui
irrite encore quelques pays un plan de
750 milliards d'euros qui seraient
empruntés sur les marchés financiers si
ce plan est validé l'europe mettrait fin
à un tabou la constitution d'une dette
commune aux pays membres de nombreuses
oppositions subsistent en particulier
dans les pays du nord
un sommet à bruxelles est prévue le mois
prochain si la crise sanitaire le permet
la chancelière allemande vise un accord
avant l'été ecoutez-la la construction
juridique proposé par la commission n'a
pas été mise en question que la
commission puisse pour ainsi dire
émettre des obligations n'a été remise
en question par personne ce n'est pas
exagéré de dire que nous sommes
confrontés aux plus grands défis
économiques de l'histoire de l'union
européenne
et voyez à présent les enjeux de ce plan
de relance européen avec pascal de lima
il est économiste et enseignant à
sciences po paris
évidemment qu'il y à de lourdes
questions qui est qui doit bénéficier de
ces montants comment suivre également la
bonne application
je dirais les bons investissements
comment ce sont des questions qui sont
loin d'être facile parce que très
souvent en europe on a depuis 2012
conditionné un certain nombre de prêts à
des plans d'austérité et à des dirait
des réformes structurelles qui sont
considérés entre guillemets plutôt
libérale on va dire donc si c'est une
grande nouvelle aujourd'hui si
l'allemagne a fait un grand pas il y a
comme vous
dites le suivi des ressources qui vont
être réalisés sous conditions et quelles
conditions et est ce que ces conditions
vont changer ou est-ce que c'est
toujours une même orthodoxie un tout
petit peu allemande que l'on connaît
bien maintenant depuis plusieurs années
s'il voulait à l'union européenne a
prolongé de six mois les sanctions
contre la russie aujourd'hui des
sanctions imposées en 2014 après le
référendum sur le rattachement de la
crimée à la russie elle devait
théoriquement expirer à la fin du mois
de juin les français moins raciste mais
des actes anti racistes en augmentation
l'an dernier c'est ce que révèle le
dernier rapport de la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme
elle a été remise et elle a été elle a
remis hier au gouvernement son rapport
annuel sur la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et la xénophobie et vous
allez le voir si les mentalités évoluent
les infractions à caractère raciste
elles ont augmenté de 11 % en un an
après quatre années de baisse
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voyez les précisions justement du
président de la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme
il y à il ya deux aspects d'une part
effectivement une augmentation des
crimes racistes des délits racistes mais
également sur doute et il faut s'en
réjouir si j'ose dire une augmentation
des déclarations car il a toujours une
sous-déclaration des injures des délits
des crimes racistes
je ne parle pas des crimes violents bien
sûr mais des délits racistes qui y sont
les injures raciales
les comportements racistes que les
victimes hésitent à déclarer ou même
quand ils les déclare que les autorités
policières sont un peu réticente a
enregistré autant maudit n'y a pas assez
de plainte les plaintes augmentent ça
veut dire la foi qui a certes une
augmentation des délits racistes mais ça
veut dire aussi une augmentation des
déclarations donc une meilleure prise en
compte par les autorités de ces délits
racistes l'eau camouflet pour l'exécutif
français après la censure par le conseil
constitutionnel du coeur du dispositif
de la loi à via une loi visant à lutter
contre les contenus haineux sur internet
qui a été jugée inconstitutionnelle
les sénateurs avaient déjà à dénoncer un
certain amateurisme dans la rédaction de
ce texte de la ministre du même nom
voyez les prési les précisions de mona à
nous dès lors sur le fond le projet doit
via et noble puisqu'il veut interdire
entre autres les contenus haineux
racistes ou terroristes mais sur la
forme c'est là que
ça se complique certaines mesures
proposées sont très difficile voire
quasiment impossible à appliquer elle si
elle l'était elle porterait atteinte à
la liberté d'expression d'une manière ou
d'une autre
une déception pour celle qui porte ce
projet doit depuis le début elle
laetitia via une députée a l'air est
mise en cause dans plusieurs affaires
assez délicate
l'intéressé aurait notamment d'après
d'anciens collaborateurs tenu des propos
racistes sexistes et homophobes
alors quand on regarde d'un peu plus
près les décisions du conseil on réalise
que c'est l'essence même de la loi qui a
été censuré le conseil constitutionnel a
rejeté plusieurs mesures
l'une d'entre elles concerne obligation
faite aux réseaux sociaux de supprimer
le contenu haineux dans les 24 heures
sous peine de sanctions pénales
un délai jugé trop court à appliquer
pour les administrateurs la peine prévue
était lourde en cas de non respect par
l'hébergeur ou l'éditeur un an
d'emprisonnement et 250000 euros damende
alors on le sait est des millions de
messages sont publiés chaque jour sur
les réseaux sociaux et faire un grand
ménage en l'espace d'une journée relève
de la mission impossible
et puis pour éviter des sanctions cette
mesure aurait pu pousser
elle est responsable à censurer tout et
n'importe quoi à partir du moment où un
signalement avait eu lieu et c'est
l'opposition qui se réjouit de cette
nouvelle écoute et lourde défaite pour
belloubet la loi via contre la haine en
ligne est quasi entièrement censurée par
le conseil constitutionnel
la volonté liberticide en échec la loi
via très largement censurée par le
conseil constitutionnel suite à la
saisine du groupe et l'air au sénat il
n'y a quasiment que le titre qui est
constitutionnel
la censure ne sera pas confiée aux gars
femmes tous ceux qui sont attachés à la
liberté devrait s'en réjouir
ce texte de loi est vivement critiquée
depuis le tout début notamment par le
conseil national numérique ou encore est
la commission consultative des droits de
l'homme
les géants du web eux étaient restés
plutôt discrets à l annonce du projet et
ils sont finalement les grands
vainqueurs de ce revers infligé à la
majorité maintenant c'est presque un
retour à la case départ pour laetitia
via puisque cette loi ne peut être ni
signée par le président
la république ni être promulguée
résultat des courses il ne reste plus
grand chose de ce projet la députée l om
va donc devoir se retrousser les manches
et présenter un nouveau texte
et voyez ce qu'en pense thierry valette
il est avocat au barreau de paris
il y avait un risque de sur censure
puisque les les amendes qui allait être
infligée sans recours sans possibilité
de réaction rapide puisque 24 heures
c'était beaucoup trop trop court pour
pouvoir saisir un juge pour savoir
exactement ce qui était ou non
dépendants de manifestement du caractère
manifestement illicite d'un bonheur
contenu
donc il est clair que les plateformes à
l'est sur réagir et les algorithmes
allait être mis en place de manière à
pouvoir enlever tous les contenus qu'ils
allaient poser un problème et donc
censuré manifestement les les
les internautes donc il est clair que
c'est les gars ça allait avoir une a
droit de vie ou de mort sur les autres
expressions ce qui n'était pas du tout
pas du tout envisageable
il est clair que là encore je le
rappelle lutter contre la haine sur
internet c'est très bien il faut le
faire mais il faut le faire en
respectant les règles de l'état de droit
et sur le plan judiciaire en france ces
nouvelles révélations dans la sphère
fillon elle a été entendue le 10 juin
dernier par la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale consacrée aux
obstacles à l'indépendance du pouvoir
judiciaire
il s'agit de l'ancienne patronne du
parquet national financiers elle a
déclaré avoir été victime de pressions
hiérarchiques pour aller plus vite et
plus loin contre françois fillon alors
qu'il faisait campagne pour la
présidentielle avec une position de
favori dans les sondages et bien un
ancien chef du parquet national
financier dit aujourd'hui regretter des
propos qui selon elle auraient été
déformés et ses propos les voici
justement regarder les demandes de
précisions de chronologie général tout
ça à deux ou trois jours d'intervalle
les demandes d'éléments sur les
auditions les demandes de notes des
conseils des mis en cause
je les ai ressenti comme une énorme
pression on ne peut que se poser des
questions c'est un contrôle très étroit
après ces révélations il ya quelques
jours du délibéré du procès de françois
fillon son avocat m antonin lévy
elle parle de fuites savamment
orchestrées pour perturber la campagne
je veux qu'on m'explique pourquoi à la
fin du quinquennat de françois hollande
avant que le gouvernement ne change le
ministère se tient au courant toutes les
48 heures des perquisitions des
audiences des notes des conseils des mis
en cause
indignation de la droite et d'une partie
de l'opposition qui parle d'
instrumentalisation de cabinet noir
d'une élection volée qui aurait privé
françois fillon de son ticket d'entrée à
l'elysée et regarder la procureure en
charge de l'affairé fillon reconnaît
avoir subi des pressions
macron à accéder au second tour de la
présidentielle 2017 par une odieuse
manipulation médiatique et judiciaire
l'élection a été truqué la légitimité de
macron est atteinte commission d'
enquête parlementaire
l'ex chef du pôle financier avoue avoir
agi sous pression dans la sphère fillon
responsable la chef du parquet qui a
ordonné des perquisitions odieuses
contre la france insoumise la vérité est
en chemin
et dire que lorsque nous dénonçons
l'instrumentalisation de la justice
certains nous traite de complotiste la
vérité éclate
et ce n'est que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg la vérité apparaît enfin sur
le plus grand hold up politique de la
vème république
la preuve d'une grande manipulation ou
le seul et unique but était d'abattre le
candidat de la droite républicaine
toujours au plan judiciaire le procès en
appel aujourd'hui à paris d'eric drouet
cette figure des gilet jaune a fait
appel de plusieurs affaires pour
lesquelles il avait été condamné l'an
dernier ont fait le point avec notre
reporter thomas bonnet sur place c'est
une procédure en appel plutôt longue
avec beaucoup de sujets abordés qui
s'est tenue cet après-midi procédure en
appel suite à la condamnation d'eric
drew est reconnu coupable d'
organisation sans déclaration préalable
des manifestations du 22 décembre 2018
et du 2 janvier 2019
il avait écopé pour cela d'une amende de
2000 euros et 500 avec sursis
eric drew et qui avaient été interpellés
les deux fois dans le quartier des
champs-elysées qui s'est toujours
défendu d'être le quelconque
organisateurs des manifestations des
idées
jaune alors certes à l'époque qu'il
jouissait d'une certaine popularité
notamment par le biais de sa page
facebook mais il se défend d'être un
leader du mouvement il est au mieux
selon lui une figure médiatique des
gilets jaunes alors est-il considéré
comme l'organisateur de ces
manifestations et bien c'est la question
qui a animé les débats évidemment pour
son avocat qui optent lara non éric
drouin ne peut pas être considéré comme
un organisateur
son avocat qui obsaar à qui est
également revenu sur ce qu'ils
considèrent comme des privations de
liberté arbitraire ou encore une
instrumentalisation de la police et une
certaine forme de complaisance du
parquet pour je cite mater les figures
du mouvement des gilets jaunes écoute et
keops lara eric drew et à la sortie de
cette audience
ça nous a permis de développer tous les
abus qui ont eu lieu concernant eric
drouhin que ce soit sur les arrestations
arbitraires que ce soit sur
l'utilisation de la police et de la
justice pour casser ce mouvement des
gels et jaune par son intermédiaire tout
ça est sortie ça a été un débat parce
qu'on a apporté aussi des éléments
nouveaux et si elle est une décision qui
je pense va être très importante qui va
arriver la cour d'appel de paris
donc du mal aussi avec le fait que tout
est parti des réseaux sociaux que tout
est organisé par des événements où il ya
des gens qui qui doivent créer des
événements etc
ils seront peu perdu avec tout ça et
aujourd'hui on était là pour leur
expliquer un petit peu et d'écrire un
peu comment ça se passe et eric deroo et
qui est également revenu sur
l'horizontalité du mouvement des gilet
jaune où personne ne peut vraiment être
tenu comme organisateurs puisque ce sont
des décisions communes qui anime les
choix des uns et des autres notamment
pour les lieux et les horaires de
manifestations eric brewer qui a pris
ses distances avec le mouvement des
gilets jaunes depuis maintenant quelques
semaines une façon pour lui de se mettre
au vert avant cette procédure judiciaire
mais il nous confier à la sortie de
cette audience qu'il pourrait réintégrer
le mouvement sous une forme ou une autre
peut-être autrement que par les
manifestations hebdomadaires du samedi
quant à cette procédure en appel
eh bien le délibéré sera rendu le 11
septembre prochain
le second tour des élections municipales
c'est dans moins de dix jours maintenant
et la grande question en cette période
de crise sanitaire c'est bien sur
l'abstention
selon une enquête de l'institut de
sondages ifop vous le voyez plus de 6
ter sur dix pourrait ne pas se rendre
aux urnes le 28 juin prochain par
crainte du virus
autre argument pour ne pas aller voter
évoquée par les sondés le délai
particulièrement longs entre le premier
tour et le second tour une élection qui
aurait dû être reporté à la rentrée
c'est ce que pense gilbert collard
député européen du rassemblement
national monsieur macro et s'en sort son
premier ministre ambulants nous hante
organiser des élections tronquées par le
fait de la delà de la pandémie il est
clair que déjà il n'ya pas un grand
engouement pour la vie démocratique dans
ce pays a vu les répétitions d'élections
mais en plus il ya cette espèce
d'inquiétude lié liés à la maladie qui
constitue un obstacle surtout chercher
chez nos aînés 1
il faut il faut bien leur dire qu'ils
doivent aller voter que c'est que c'est
le prix de leur liberté et qui n'ont
qu'à mettre comme moi un masque en les
dispenses départ mais du tuyau mais il
met un masque et ils vont voter les
français ne se désintéresse pas de de la
stature du maire il reste un peu quelque
part le médecin de famille mais
malheureusement il ya de moins en moins
de maires qui sont restés des médecins
de famille voilà ça c'est dommage
et on peut rêver d'avoir de nouveau des
médecins de famille comme mère parce que
ça crée un lien de promis de grosses
quilles et de proximité d'amitié de
fraternité quelques parrains et les les
électeurs ont envie d'aller voter mais
on leur a mis des obstacles les
obstacles liés à l'inquiétude de la
maladie et ça on n'y peut
malheureusement rien c'est la faute du
gouvernement moi je pense qu'ils
auraient dû reporter les élections au
mois de septembre
et puis quand même ils ont donné un
sacré avantage au maire sortant un bon
j'en connais quelques-uns qui ont
profité de la de la pandémie pour se
faire sur le dos de la maladie des
inquiétudes
une propagande est effréné et plutôt
bien parti dans cette élection
municipale les écologistes avec de bons
scores au premier tour vous voyez la
déclaration à présent d'hervé manchon
candidat europe ecologie les verts à
marseille on attend des élus aux mains
vertes et aux mains propres c'est à dire
d'une part répondre aux urgences
environnementales et climatiques mais
aussi répondre aux questions posées par
le manque de justice sociale et pas
seulement justice environnementale et
puis une plus grande transparence une
démocratie plus directe
il y à une attente pour des gouvernants
qui pratiquerait une politique autrement
il ya eu des signaux très forts de
dérèglement climatique d'urgence panne
et r2 de deux zones terrestres que l'on
prévoit comme étant les futurs de
futures zones inhabitables avec des gens
pourtant qui vivent encore dessus il y a
aussi une des choses qui interroge notre
mode de vie
par exemple quand quand la pandémie a
été annoncée à la veille du scrutin du
premier tour
beaucoup ont fui les villes et sont
allés dans les
dans des résidences secondaires ce n'est
pas seulement une fuite une peur du
vieux ça interroge notre mode de vie
on a des villes invivable on a un bien
vivre qui est une attente forte mais
auquel les métropoles et les villes ne
répondent pas encore les espaces
urbanisés son sont encore sur un vieux
logiciel sur le logiciel du monde
d'après tout comme le monde économique
est encore sur le logiciel productiviste
et et ultralibéral voilà et nous nous
répondons à ces inquiétudes face à ces
logiciels nous y répondons nous sommes
porteurs de d'avenir les commémoration
de l'abolition de l'esclavagé aux états
unis sur fond de tensions raciales avec
toujours ces opérations de décrochage
des figures contestée du passé à
washington.les fort très de 4 confédérés
ont été enlevés des couloirs du congrès
certaines marques américaines ont aussi
décidé de changer leur image
regardez
[Musique]
oh
un changement d'image pour les marques
nécessaire pour aurélie des lignes elle
est professeur associé à laquelle je
business school regardez une mars est
une personne morale une marque une
personne morale qu'est un rôle à jouer
dans la société qui leur fait cette
société là aujourd'hui
les lignes bougent les limites bouge ça
fait quand même plusieurs années il faut
réaliser que il ya plusieurs
associations de consommateurs qui
demande à ses marques la ddt d'arrêter
d'utiliser ces symboles ségrégationniste
qui rappelle un passé qui aujourd'hui
est complètement hors hors de vue les
marques aujourd'hui réagissent plutôt
elle aurait pu être pratique mais elles
réagissent mais il paraît essentiel pour
moi oui de d'être à l'image de la
société de porter les valeurs de la
société dans laquelle on vit ça a un
impact majeur quand on sait le poids et
les investissements qu'il faut pour
faire retenir le nom d'une marque
l'imagerie d'un logo à des consommateurs
saadé concède et des conséquences qui
sont tout à fait non donc c'est là
qu'intervient un travail marketing de se
dire mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
suffisamment s'éloigner de cette
identité qui ne nous convient plus pour
en trouver une qui soit proche de nos
valeurs actuelles sans complètement se
dissocier et sortir finalement de
l'espace qu'on occupait dans la mémoire
des consommateurs donc ça va vraiment
être un jeu d'équilibriste pour se
retrouver une identité mais qui ne soit
pas trop loin non plus de ce que l'on a
réussi à construire dans l'esprit des
consommateurs central cris et qui est
loin d'être évident et qui a des
conséquences économiques et financières
extrêmement lourde et c'est en ce jour
de commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé aux états unis que donald
trump avait choisi d'organiser son
premier grand meeting de campagne et il
a choisi la ville de tulsa dans
l'oklahoma un choix polémique puisque
c'est dans cette ville que 300 afro
américains avaient été massacrés en 1921
le président américain a reporté son
grand meeting à demain sans changer le
lieu de son rendez vous de campagne
la crise sanitaire en inde avec 2000
morts ces dernières 24 heures le nombre
de décès y atteint
11000 à 900 morts un rebond qui pousse
vous allez le voir les autorités à
imposer de nouvelles restrictions
sanitaires le détail en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la crise au liban avec la poursuite là
et ces poursuites engagées par le
procureur financier contre le patron de
l'une des plus grandes banques du pays
elle est française
la livre libanaise qui continue dans le
même temps sa chute face au dollar le
pdg de la société générale de banque au
liban
antoine sehnaoui a été déféré devant un
juge d'instruction pour violation dû
code de change est atteinte au prestige
de l'état il ne s'est pas présenté hier
à l'audience
la semaine dernière c'est un député du
hezbollah qui avait accusé la banque
d'achat massive de dollars sur le marché
libanais afin de les transférer à
l'étranger crise monétaire et crise
économique sur fond de défiance de la
population vis-à-vis du pouvoir voyez
l'analyse de fouad zmokhol il est
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et des chefs d'entreprise
libanais premier on a perdu complètement
la confiance des exploités qui n'exporte
plus aucun centime au liban la deuxième
chose on a plus on a perdu la confiance
de la communauté internationale qui ne
va surtout pas supporté le gouvernement
dans des conditions actuelles on a perdu
la confiance des exportations libanaises
qui n'ont plus de matières premières
pour pour produire et on a peu plus la
confiance des touristes soit des bannis
ou autres qui vont venir investir donc
on a perdu complètement l'offre des
devises au liban et au niveau de la
demande la demande a été multiplié par
mille parce que finalement la demande
qu'on avait avant qu'il venait
simplement au commerce son industrie à
certaines familles qui avaient des
parents en dehors du pays
aujourd'hui on a six millions de
demandeurs parce que ils vont vers les
monnaies d'euros et de dollars qui sont
les monnaies refuges
nous savons qu'il ya une bonne partie
qui va de façon illégale en syrie
d'après l'application de l'app de césar
dont il ya un manque de davis donc
l'équilibré complètement perdu et la
balance aussi et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité sur
notre antenne
on se retrouva dans 30 minutes rester
avec nous
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
le président brésilien g1 black sun araw
ni la gravité lada pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît ou aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]